today we got a good look at cyberpunk's
tools of destruction
the next call of duty has been teased
again and the last of us part two
is getting a permadeath mode i'm persia
and this is your safe state for monday
august 10th
cd projekt red's second night city wire
stream went down this morning
which showcased different life paths you
can take in cyberpunk 2077
but it also showed off a bunch of new
weapons that you'll find on the way
the newest weapons were featured by
categories like power
tech and more with each category having
their own perks and abilities
power weapons like the carnage shotgun
have bullets that can ricochet
while smart weapons have homing rounds
that will follow targeted
enemies melee weapons like the thermal
katana are best suited for close range
combat with its ripping hot steel
paired with various cyberware that can
give you special abilities like
literally having missiles up your sleeve
is starting to look like we'll have a
wide variety of ways to fight
if you want all the details on today's
night city wire stream and weapons then
be sure to visit gamespot.com
activision sent some strange boxes to
call of duty streamers and fan sites
that contained
50 styles projectors and mysterious
slides we can only assume that this is
another teaser of what's next in the
series but
no official word has been given yet on
if it's black ops cold war related or
not
the slide shows satellite imagery maps
and an assortment of other things and
the internet is
already speculating on multiple
possibilities fans pointed out
similarities between the slides and
multiplayer maps like summit with
treyarch's official twitter
even changing their cover photo to a
shot of snowy mountains in the middle of
all of this mystery
the teasers seem to be piling in now as
players have also been getting cryptic
in-game messages in warzone this is all
starting to seem in line with
when we're used to getting new call of
duty news so what are you hoping to see
in the next game
two new trophies patched into the last
of us part 2
have hinted at the return of the
grounded difficulty
as well as a new perma-death mode if you
played part 1 then you may remember
the grounded difficulty that removed
your hud and disabled listen mode
well now you'll get your chance to give
it a go in part 2 along with a new
perma-death mode
not much else to explain when it comes
to perma-death because if you die
it's game over but the trophy says you
can complete the story on any setting
which sounds like it's going to be much
easier on lower difficulties if
you're just trying to snag the trophy
quickly
that's all for today in terms of news
but if you have
an extra minute then stop by
story.gamespot.com and check out
all of our play for all merch the
proceeds are being donated to black
lives matter and coveted 19 relief
efforts until the end of august
thanks for stopping by feel free to give
me a follow on twitter at persia
underscore xo and make sure you meet us
here tomorrow for your next save state
see you later
[Music]